you have this show called hello ladies
right and you're coming to Scandinavia
with it and and it's it's very much
about you trying to find a girlfriend
well it's it's a very personal show it
is a personal show yeah it's a stand-up
comedy show and it's one that I i-i've
done Oh in America now and I've done it
in Australia New Zealand and it began
life as me um I suppose if you like
talking about my search for a wife ah
which is not going well um and this is
actually true I mean this is this is
true this is how are your life is thank
you
yes no no I'm not looking for a wife
actively in the show but it's about my
sort of stories of sort of romantic
misfortune of the years and in the
various ways that I guess I thought
things maybe would change once I'd be on
TV and things like that did it since
I've been on TV I I notice I get
rejected by even more beautiful women
like you know me now I'm getting
rejected by models actresses there's
beautiful women who said no to me is
this how it is when it when you get
famous that's a I don't know I've always
been married I mean second second wife
present wife last wife and I mean put
the two together and it's about 35 years
trying to find a wife was never the
problem it was the other the other the
other easing how many bigamy is having
sex with spies it's a very different
life I mean what do you mean this is
crazy I was distance I couldn't believe
because my hero was always James Bond as
a teenager I was obsessed with James
Bond that was James Bond someone that
you kind of was a was he ever in your
radar that it seems so absurd to you
because you knew what real spies were
like no James Bond is hokum of course
yeah no don't never emulate oakum I did
though this is the poem I grew up just I
was obsessed with James Bond I was
obsessed with with Roger Morris James
Bond and it's weird isn't it because
when you're a teenager identify with him
what I mean of the all the days we were
both British so we had in common
it's funny how as time goes on you sort
of you you know you kind of my heroes
now or my heroes Frederick now for
having no escaping assassins and having
sex with spies it's incredible you've
been married for 40 years 40 years could
you please help it what would be your
best advice I mean oh you found each
other you were like we were highschool
sweethearts then it's a yeah
there she was she took pity on you but
no I was it she's just a tremendous gift
and you know I wanted to make sure that
she knew um from the beginning how much
of a gift she is and so I you know I
just look at her and I she's the most
beautiful woman I know and I love her
with all my heart well you're very lucky
very lucky you
you just never got that gift didn't it
I'm still looking for the game yeah I'm
looking for the guest and maybe I'll
find it in Scandinavia when I do this
tour it's from the teenager so I mean
speaking of teenagers you how do you how
do you relate to teenagers today I mean
you haven't you tell that's so
terrifying they don't seem to understand
reason you know I mean they just they
play by their own rules
they're like crazed you know irrational
irrational they like terrifying like
zombies I can't actually understand what
you mean because it's very it's very
hard to understand it's very I find it
hard to amuse them or impress them yes
exactly it's very hard to sort of
because I have I have an interesting job
but when I come home and tell them who I
met it's like they don't care they don't
care they're not interested and you as a
father you want to impress them yeah no
exactly and I've never and I and I and I
am and I thought you know having been on
TV and stuff that I would impress them
but exactly it makes no difference you
you you've been your career has been you
over not to to Ricky Gervais as the
Ricky Gervais is over you right in a way
ah you created the office together right
and and then the extras a lot a lot of
other comedy series
I wonder who I mean he's he's older than
you
mm-hmm is he a sort of father figure
oh no no no no definitely not
uh no it's well I mean on occasion give
Mike an older brother on occasion he is
offered good advice and I'm when I first
moved to London he was very he was very
helpful um but I feel often that I've
been more I won't say a father for but
like sometimes like a mother sometimes
like an overbearing mother
yeah I remember the first time we went
to the Golden Globes ceremony we want
you gone Globes no no like this stop it
stop yeah um I think I think they got it
yeah oh yeah and we went to the Glen
Tony and we'd never been anywhere that
was so exciting and it was so glamorous
and you know and you fight hard to not
be overwhelmed and enchanted by that
stuff but it is really when there's
movie stars and big TV stars and people
and and we got picked up in a limousine
I remember from the airport and we drove
and I never been in a limousine before
and it was just incredible we were just
you know closing and opening the windows
cuz we could and we get to the hotel and
check again this will pay for everything
and then the next day they they pick you
up you're in a tuxedo and and I bought a
200 pound tuxedo no expense spared for
the Golden Globes and are we getting
this in this limousine and it's amazing
how quickly you were climatized to this
thick because I remember we got in the
limousine the next day and we're like
this one's not as big as the one from
yesterday we're already kind of acting
like divas and we went there we got the
ceremony and they we were BBC had said
you're not gonna win you're not gonna
win there was no chance you're gonna win
and when you look at the finished TV
coverage of it they called our name
amazingly and then the cameras are
looking for us and it can't even find us
it doesn't know who we aren't searching
for us and eventually I sort of pop up
freakishly tall and there's kind of
squat a little rickety like these freaks
wandering through this beautiful this
beautiful landscape of gorgeous people
and Tom Cruise and stuff and and I
remember they didn't even know they'd
even know who we were so they must have
assumed we were French because Ricky's
last name is french-canadian so the
unites are said coming to the stage
Ricky Gervais and stupid
classy and we got onto the stage I
remember we were there and I'm not
joking I I remember looking out
I remember seeing Clint Eastwood turn to
someone next to him and went who the
are they and go and in a way that's
sort of but that joy of that excitement
of feeling like you're sort of part of
something exclusive and rarified that's
never gone away and it still is it's
still dazzling and exciting there and
I'm getting you you you stand out in
Hollywood because that's what it was
actors yeah Hollywood actors are really
very often returning every time every
tiny yeah I stop these yeah well I guess
it's because they fit on the screen
easier you'll find mostly when I'm on TV
I'm sat down a great deal or just
leaning on things
hey come in and my height is very odd
because it's a very I'm sort of tutorial
I'm six foot seven which is too big for
cars and it's too big for Hollywood and
it's sort of too big generally in life
and you can sort of see me anywhere in
any crowd
I remember we saw like trying to find
girls I yeah I was I was done in
Trafalgar Square in in London in New
Year once and and I don't even been in
Trafalgar I'm sure they have it in it
any kind of big city centre but there's
a sea of people at new years but five
minutes to midnight and I was stood
there and I was sort of stood you know
kind of just checking the girls out I
just see what's happening and this
girl's crossed away and she sort of made
her way towards me through the crowd I
thought here we go
she's seen me on TV occasionally guys
lot lots of strangers even my friends
doctors and this girl comes up to me and
she says excuse me are you gonna be here
for a while
and I said yes I am and she said great
because my friends and I have arranged
to meet back at you
[Applause]
in Trafalgar Square where there's no
other obvious landmark
Happy New Year Happy New Year yeah I
remember Xin her a bunch of her friends
gathered around me about five minutes
past midnight and then they went off to
a party and I went home to my mouldy fat
success having a lot of success and I'm
I'm sure you you know a bit about that
as well does it change the way you work
I think so I think mommy I mean here you
go honey
well if imagine can you still worried
about money
can you still be like yeah of course
yeah no I always worry about money cuz I
didn't have any when I was younger and
and you know and my father was always
very careful with money and and it sort
of instructed me to be the same and so
we are you know very careful um and and
missing what sense well you know I mean
on a date I don't see why I
automatically should pick up the tab I
don't understand it's just just cuz I've
made some money and with a lady in a
white one she I'm just gonna pay you for
dessert because you want a dessert I'm
having a dessert you want a dessert pay
for a dessert or if you try and pay if
you've got one of those like two-for-one
meal vouchers from the newspaper what's
wrong with that
why isn't that attractive I should be
attractive that should suggest that if
we go further we end up get married that
I'm gonna be a provider I'm not gonna be
blowing money on booze and fast cars
that's just it why that's not seen it's
sexy being careful with money should be
sex that's I don't understand him but
then you know I'm not a woman I are you
you're going just kind of a via that's
right uh have you been there before
never been there before when you travel
like that are you are you uh sort of a
global Globetrotter guy or are you more
like a scary is it just scary
I still wear um a money belt underneath
my shirt when I travel flesh-colored so
discreet um even to Scandinavia yes of
course I don't trust you people don't
know you people you seem a nice guy but
I don't know you really I mean I know
it's not assault again it's not very
sexy when you try and buy a girl in the
bar you just have to do that so I didn't
know who he was but he knew who I was
and the phone rang and his voice said
get the hell out of Hamburg in about
five minutes
don't pack just grab a passport and go